[Music]
ultimately do you feel vindicated today
yes today I honestly can say that I feel
like the like you know the public they
just wanted to see like she's like lucid
I'm Lucy we're swimming around Corinne
and de Mario hit it off instantly in
paradise but accusations of
inappropriate behavior shut down
production just two days in post Chris
Harrison was seen awkwardly addressing
the incident on an empty set but never
really seemed to answer the question
what really happened what we saw is you
guys very early in the day going to the
pool together fully clothed you're
snuggling so when did the incident
happen was that later in the night time
yes didn't happen right after that
that's when we had kind of got you know
a little more cozier
you know so to speak I think currents
people have said that the incident
happened later in the day in a hot tub
and that's 100% false once a pager
Warner Brothers the production company
behind the show ultimately cleared
Corinne and de Mario of any misconduct
for de Mario the ordeal really hit home
I feel guilty like because my mom like
didn't sign up for this have you spoken
to Corinne recently when was the last
time you guys talked oh no we haven't
spoke since was it that's his paradise
if she was here what would you want to
say to her I love her I'm here for stay
strong don't let the people who weren't
there
alter your judgment
[Music]
you